en fait avec le collectif Ibiza on a
fait plusieurs actions depuis l'histoire
de Jean-Michel sosy et il se trouve que
le lendemain du premier tour on était
censé se retrouver pour préparer une
autre action et en fait on était tous un
peu sonnés il y avait des militants
écolos mais il y a aussi des gens de la
France insoumise dans notre collectif et
des gens pas encarter et on se dit en
fait là on arrête toutes nos actions
tout ce qu'on doit faire pendant deux
semaines c'est essayer de montrer le
danger de Marine Le Pen qui peut passer
au second tour parce qu'aujourd'hui elle
peut passer pas parce que les gens vont
voter Le Pen ou pas parce que les gens
sont devenus racistes mais parce que
beaucoup de gens vont ne peuvent pas
rejeter Macron encore une fois vous
allez voter maintenant ben oui je pense
en me pince en le nez en regardant
ailleurs mais oui je vais voter Macron
mais le problème c'est qu'en fait il y a
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui en fait il
y a des gens qui ont été mutilés il y a
des gens il y a en fait les violences
faites aux femmes ça a été absolument
pas adressé il y a eu Gérald Darmanin
qui explique aux femmes vous inquiétez
pas ça va bien se passer et qui parle de
en parlant de ce qui s'est passé pour
moi ils ont dit oui ils l'ont saisi un
peu virilement
vous avez infiltré cette conférence de
presse vous êtes fait passer pour des
journalistes de la chaîne alors moi je
me suis fait passer pour une
journaliste d'une radio étudiante qui
n'existe pas mais on a été accrédité
pour cette radio étudiante qui n'existe
pas d'accord alors donc vous qui vous a
foutu dehors alors la personne qui m'a
mise dehors à la fin mais il y a
plusieurs personnes la personne à la fin
c'est un policier la personne parce
qu'il y a des gens qui disent que c'est
des fois c'est le privé c'est la
sécurité de Marine Le Pen il y en a qui
disent que c'est les personnes de voilà
c'est du ministre de l'Intérieur donc de
Gérald Darmon alors le bras là c'est
quelqu'un de la sécurité de Marine Le
Pen là le SP je sais pas quoi en tout
cas lui il me l'a dit comment Protection
Sécurité
lui me l'a dit parce qu'on a parlé après
c'est lui c'est celui qui me traîne
est-ce qu'il est sympa je sais pas moi
il a voulu il a voulu m'enfermer dans
les toilettes donc là j'ai un peu peur
et j'ai dit non en fait vous allez pas
me mettre dans les toilettes mais donc
lui il m'a tiré voilà ce monsieur là
d'accord
la personne qui m'a fait mal un peu et
qui s'est jeté sur moi je sais pas qui
sait en fait c'est peut-être c'est un
policier ok le premier qui s'est jeté
sur elle c'est un policier d'accord
manon a parlé parce que Marine Le Pen a
menti sur BFM TV en disant que c'était
oui comme souvent donc c'est la mentir
elle a dit que c'était toutes les
équipes flics de Darmanin ce qu'il faut
mais le vrai le vrai qu'il a plaqué
d'abord c'est un slip donc c'est un
policier c'est vrai et ensuite celui qui
l'a traîné comme elle l'a dit donc
les deux équipes donc voilà donc
là bien sûr alors est-ce que vous
regrettez votre geste ou pas du tout non
pas du tout ce qu'on voulait c'était
qu'on
fait mal il y a pas eu de en fait je
suis allé voir le médecin cet après-midi
donc c'est bon j'ai pas de traumatisme
crânien mais j'ai tout le coup et
l'arrière du dos un peu bloqué mais
normalement ça devrait passer donc c'est
pas c'est pas trop grave alors est-ce
que vous comprenez ce qui s'est passé
pierre gentil vous êtes à comprendre
dans le sens où
vous avez reçu votre couple
félicitations bravo la preuve c'est
qu'on en parle ce soir donc en fait
voilà vous vous êtes en direct à quoi je
veux dire vous intervenez dans un
endroit vous êtes enfin vous n'êtes pas
vous êtes invités mais en fait vous
auriez pas dû être invité vous êtes
évacué alors
je vous dis il y a quelqu'un qui m'écrit
et qui connaît vraiment d'autres voilà
elle est plaquée au sol par un policier
du ministère de l'Intérieur qui assure
la protection de Marine Le Pen voilà
elle est avec protection Marisa et
t'assurer donc par un c'est ce que vous
il paraît policier du ministère
d'intérieur elle est ensuite évacuée à
l'extérieur par le service d'ordre du RN
et la police ensemble conjointement
voilà c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé hier voilà on verra on verra de
toute façon je sais pas si vous portez
plainte Vous portez plainte ou pas c'est
encore une option géré donc on verra
pour voir si les responsabilités sont
établies à ce moment-là et je pense que
de toute façon l'enjeu l'enjeu il est
pas là oui bah l'enjeu il est pas là on
a bien compris que l'enjeu c'est que
pour vous alors vous avez brandi on a vu
c'est un petit cœur avec la rencontre
entre Vladimir Poutine et Marine Le Pen
et moi je comprends votre discours et
aussi à vos prises de position que dans
votre univers mental si le rassemblement
national demain arrive au pouvoir on est
entre l'apartheid et le national
socialiste allemand alors et si je me
permets de terminer je pense qu'en fait
vous devriez en parler du programme tout
à l'heure je vous ai écouté par le
programme vous devriez voir que en
matière programmatique je parle même pas
de l'économie moi je n'aime pas aller
sur ce secteur là c'est que des deux
candidats celui qui permet de donner la
parole aux Français à travers le RIC ou
à travers des référendum il y en a qu'un
plutôt il y en a qu'une c'est Marine Le
Pen donc en termes de respect de la
démocratie en termes de respect de ce
qui peut rester des tas de droit en
principe vous auriez plus intérêt à ne
pas soutenir Emmanuel Macron parce que
on a eu un quinquennat autoritaire il
faut le dire un quinquennat autoritaire
ou une apparition
qui nous confirme ce qu'on a dit donc
voilà donc
l'événement je ne sais pas je me
est-ce que c'est normal de sortir une
une dame comme ça d'une salle à manger
ce qui fait polémique c'est que ce
policier a été suspendu on lui a retiré
sa mission d'accord alors c'est presque
automatique parce que Marine Le Pen a
signalé l'acte de ce policier dans ces
cas-là on estime qu'il ne peut plus la
protéger alors la grande monde chez les
policiers parce que lui il a fait son
boulot si vous voulez il estime avoir
fait son boulot maintenant ce qui pose
énormément problème monsieur c'est la
manière dont pauline est brutalement
éjecté tiré par la main comme ça ça pose
un énorme problème moi pour le coup je
vais défendre Marine Le Pen moi je pense
qu'on est en train d'instrumentaliser
cette image pour faire passer Marine Le
Pen et rassemblement national pour un
parti violent et quand on y réfléchit
politique ou pas politique vous êtes
dans un événement public avec une
personnalité publique qui est
potentiellement peut être attaqué elle a
dit Marine Le Pen n'aurait j'aurais pu
être agressé ou attaqué vous avez une
personne qui interrompt le qui
interrompt l'événement pardon vous avez
une personne qui interrompre l'événement
alors s'il vous plaît
vous vous êtes de quel journal
excusez-moi
pardon vous avez une paire non mais vous
êtes dans un événement public avec une
personnalité qui peut être
potentiellement agressé vous avez une
personne qui interrompre cet événement
c'est normal qu'elle se fasse sortir de
la sécurité par la sécurité et parfois
de manière un peu virulente
qui a des pacifiquement Benhaïm Valérie
Benaim alors ça et je l'ai dit pour tous
les meetings ça aurait été pour Emmanuel
Macron c'est comme la claque d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est comme le mec qui vient à
côté
d'Emmanuel Macron la semaine d'avant
nous le même collectif Ibiza la semaine
d'avant on était au meeting d'Emmanuel
Macron on a déroulé dans une banderole
criminel climatique on sait pas du tout
fait sortir dans la même manière le
problème c'est que est-ce qu'on sait pas
ce que peuvent sortir aussi comme m'a
dit Raymond on sait jamais non mais
ouais mais bon on sait jamais on dit un
cœur et en fait il peut me soulever par
les bras mais je pense que me taper la
tête contre le sol en main l'erreur
c'est que tu vas là-bas on va dire voilà
je vais parler cru tu as foutu le bordel
l'erreur c'est que tu es pas à portée de
Marine Le Pen ils peuvent te mettre au
sol comme ils t'ont mis et il doit te
dire ils peuvent te dire Madame
relevez-vous tout de suite ils peuvent
te dire relevez-vous non là ils te
console il te traite par terre et vous
parlez de ils sont gentils ils sont pas
méchants même Guillaume les Femen à
Opéra moi j'ai le souvenir des femelles
qui avaient manifesté place de l'Opéra
au deuxième étage d'un immeuble ils sont
partis les chercher et ils ont giflé ils
ont le service d'or de Marine Le Pen a
fait ça donc il faut pas dire que le
service d'ordre de Marine Le Pen il est
gentilateurs
il s'appelle Pierre gentillet remets
l'image et regarde les secondes entre le
moment qu'elle est au sol et le moment
qu'elle est traîner compte les secondes
avec moi oh on fait quoi on est où là ok
ok
pardonnez-moi non mais attendez on peut
pas dire que c'est des images ultra
violentes
de ces gens qui disent si jamais il y a
des gens il y a des gens qui disent
parce que si la sécurité lui avait
demandé poliment de partir est-ce que
vous seriez parti nous on a on voit bien
que j'oppose absolument aucune
résistance moi mon seul objectif et vous
avez raison j'ai atteint mon objectif
mon seul parti non pas du tout mon seul
objectif c'est de dire que Marine Le Pen
présidente aujourd'hui la France elle
serait complice de Poutine dans des de
guerre en Ukraine c'est ça la position
du Front national elle soutient
et justement à votre surprise si vous
étiez pendant une heure elle a parlé de
maintenir les sanctions contre la loyers
Marine Le Pen elle sera accomplisse de
guerre de machin de soucis de cela
c'était dans ton combat c'est très bien
tu as montré ta photo là c'est très bien
pour moi je te l'ai dit la première
partie la première partie ils ont pas à
te coucher enfin ils te couche au sol ok
ils doivent te dire Madame levez-vous
maintenant ils doivent rester en sortir
pas de te traîner comme une serpillière
comme ça maintenant sur ton combat de
dire Marine Le Pen à faire machin à
faire tu es pas dans l'avenir on peut
pas savoir voilà
en fait Marine Le Pen elle a déjà été
élu au Parlement européen à l'Assemblée
nationale et moi je suis une jeune femme
de 26 ans et Marine Le Pen quand elle
vote elle vote contre mes droits par
exemple moi la plupart de mes amis on a
une femme sur trois dans sa vie elle va
avoir recours à l'interruption
volontaire de bruyère Marine Le Pen elle
lutte contre ce droit c'est un droit que
moi je vais perdre que je peux perdre
dans un an et on a qu'on s'en rend pas
compte aujourd'hui
l'environnement dans la conférence moi
je l'ai écouté
sur la terre moi j'ai écouté ça
conférence pendant une heure parce qu'en
fait avant de faire l'action j'ai laissé
dérouler sa conférence avant qu'on pose
notre question pendant sa conférence
elle dit deux choses sur les droits des
femmes et sur l'environnement elle
explique en gros elle ça diplomatie et
ben c'est avec mes mots que je le résume
mais elle va pas se faire chier avec ses
conneries diplomatie féministes avec
l'environnement on va pas se laisser
dicter notre agenda par le chèque le
chèque il nous dit qu'on a plus de 3 ans
pour agir pour rester sur un monde
viable et Marine Le Pen elle nous dit
dans sa conférence de presse sur sa
diplomatie je vais pas me faire chier
avec ses conneries d'environnement et de
politique féministe moi ça met en danger
mon avenir et en fait ça met notre
danger notre avenir à nous tous mais
juste jusqu'à présent est-ce que Macron
a fait quelque chose pour
l'environnement ça c'est ma petite
question effectivement le référendum
c'est très intéressant parce que si elle
elle est au pouvoir elle elle va donner
la parole aux Français et moi je suis
pas du tout pour ces images attends je
suis pas du tout pour ces images
gratuit et tout le monde prendre un
droit d'aller au phasmes
vous étiez meilleur
de te traîner au sol franchement moi je
suis pas du tout pour ça mais j'aimerais
juste te demander donc ce cœur tu as mis
Marine Le Pen et Poutine mais tu aurais
pu mettre parce que des serrages de main
il y en a eu plusieurs tu aurais pu
mettre Macron et Poutine tu aurais pu me
résidence du président
en fait le parti de Macron n'est pas
financé par la Russie et par ailleurs
moi jamais jamais tu ne m'entendras
défendre le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron moi
je suis militante écologiste et élu
écologiste et je sais la catastrophe
dès le lendemain du second tour en fait
le soir du second tour on a déjà une
action prévue contre Macron pour lui
dire en fait c'est pas un bon moment
de faire une action contre Emmanuel
Macron quand il va être réel ça tu as
fait 4 % non mais regarde non mais c'est
rien alors 63 ma chérie c'est tout on va
aller
tu vas aller tu viens de dire un truc et
Emmanuel Macron il va être cru j'ai
[ __ ] la merde et ben tu as fait 4 % tu
es même pas remboursé donc là tu as plus
d'éoliennes que de personnes qui ont
voté pour vous là vous arrêtez
[Applaudissements]
arrête
arrête-toi tu vas aller prendre des
grains de maïs tu vas leur [ __ ] dans
la pub arrête ce que je vais faire avec
les 4,6 enfin les quatre 63 %, c'est
vrai qu'il faut aller sur soutenir
l'écologie.fr
[Musique]
vous ne respectez 63 vous savez
respecter mais vous ne respectez pas le
scrutin celui qui doit être le plus
dégoûté c'est Jean-Luc voilà mais lui il
est passé à ça
d'environnement
il y a des militants
écologie voilà c'est mon tour on fait
quoi alors maintenant lequel est plus
sur l'entrée moi je pensais pas parce
qu'on a perdu le début d'une course
qu'il faut se couper les deux jambes
pour continuer à la course
ça se passe à Emmanuel Macron oh on peut
le détester autant qu'on veut et je
pense que je le déteste autant que vous
mais aujourd'hui Marine Le Pen c'est
difficile de penser que ça doit être
pire je suis poli moi je te dis les
actions après que ce Intel moi-même ça y
est les Français ils ont voté fallait
faire plus alors dans ce cas là même une
Hidalgo elle va faire quoi elle va faire
des travaux non
en fait le vrai problème si vous voulez
vous c'est j'ai l'impression que vous
n'acceptez pas le fait démocratique vous
me parlez en permanence d'État droit de
respect et cetera là les deux candidats
qui sont au second tour qu'on le veuille
ou non c'est Emmanuel Macron contre
Marine Le Pen donc arrêtez de parler de
3e course de quatrième tour et cetera il
faut se faire à l'idée que il va y avoir
un vainqueur et vous devrez respecter
sur le résultat parce que vous
respecterez la démocratie et après
effectivement et là les sensibilités
pourront peut-être même plus s'exprimer
au niveau du Parlement donc le vrai
problème c'est qu'en fait vous
n'acceptez pas les opinions politiques
différentes des autres et ça correspond
tout à fait à l'idéologie qui est la
vôtre qui est le logis d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts vous êtes dans une vision ou
c'est pas je suis d'accord pas d'accord
c'est vous êtes méchant et moi je suis
gentil vous êtes dans une vision qui est
une vision caricaturale de la politique
et c'est une vision anti-démocratique
est-ce que Tariq frérot est-ce que tu
peux aller chercher mon fils lino à
Montorgueil parce que je dois le voir ce
soir et il y a sa mère
au plus vite à Montorgueil il mange à la
maison ce soir merci
[Applaudissements]
à ma grand-mère
oui
je voudrais revenir au gestes le fait
que Pauline a été sorti brutalement du
meeting il s'est passé la même chose et
on peut pas le taire lors d'un discours
d'Emmanuel Macron à Strasbourg
mais regardez la personne est traînée
Cyril sur le fait que quand des gens mon
fils comme ça
quand des gens interviennent comme ça
dans un meeting il y a une réaction fort
qui est qui est disproportionnée qui me
scandalise mais elle me scandalise de la
même manière la regarder comme cette
personne est traînée là ça ne va pas du
tout donc Marine Le Pen n'a pas le
monopole de la brutalité pour sortir des
gens d'un meeting ou d'une réunion c'est
ce que je voulais dire parce que ça me
semble rétablir j'aimerais revenir
les gens qui disent après les élections
on va
[Musique]
je ne comprends pas ce monde où tout
d'un coup vous n'êtes pas d'accord il y
a des élections il y aura les élections
législatives vous pouvez vous êtes déjà
lancé en politique vous pouvez combattre
des idées mais là vous mentez vous
rentrez illégalement puisque vous avez
menti sur moi j'ai adoré hein ce que
vous faisiez avec Blanquer c'était drôle
c'était dehors il y a longtemps très
bien
en Viking mais là je ne comprends pas
alors on gifle on n'est pas d'accord on
gifle Macron on rentre illégalement dans
un réservation
on va être comme ça
mais en fait le truc qui est assez que
les gens ne peuvent pas savoir que les
actions sont non violente un moment on
peut pas savoir
il y a une jeune fille hier
j'étais très sympathique qui s'est levé
qui a créé chez lui
je sais plus qui voilà ils ont eu peur
donc forcément tu vois il y a une
réaction on peut pas savoir alors que la
jeune fille on l'a parlé avec nous on
était très content de la laisser parler
mais c'est vrai qu'à maman on peut pas
savoir
[Applaudissements]
d'amener des sujets sur la table
aujourd'hui nous ce qui nous fait peur à
ma génération c'est que on parle de
Marine Le Pen comme si c'était juste une
candidate parmi notre qui aimait les
chats et qui était sympathique
ce qui va se passer est-ce que vous
pensez je pose une question est-ce que
vous pensez sérieusement que si demain
Marine Le Pen et élu et si elle a une
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale que il
n'y a plus d'expression d'expression
démocratique en France parce que c'est
vraiment ce que vous pensez Marine Le
Pen n'est pas encore élu et qu'elle a
déjà commencé
je suis en train de vous répondre il me
semble qu'elle est pas encore élue et
qu'elle a déjà commencé à décider à quel
journaliste elle répondait à quelle
journée ça répondait pas et qu'elle a
expliqué qu'elle ferait ça une fois
que le quotidien bébé cnews et tout ça
un côté des qui vous intéresse de dire à
ne pas parler à ces journalistes là et
d'où vient l'argent d'où vient l'argent
d'Emmanuel Macron on sait pas peut-être
qu'on sera un jour d'où vient son argent
on sait pas de et lui aussi il
il veut pas d'où vient votre argent
je vais savoir revenir que ça va chier
les mecs carnets vous avez pas répondu
en attendant vous pensez vraiment que ça
va être l'éducation en France je pense
qu'on va faire ça à une vraie
restriction de nos libertés je pense
qu'on ne prend pas conscience du danger
que représente l'extrême droite et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il y a un truc
dont on a pas conscience il y a beaucoup
de gens la majorité des gens ne veulent
pas que Marine Le Pen soit élu mais
beaucoup de gens ne vont pas s'exprimer
par Marine Le Pen les gens ne veulent
pas que Marine Le Pen soit élu mais la
plupart des gens vont juste se dire je
ne peux pas remettre un bulletin
Emmanuel Macron dans Lyon et c'est comme
ça qu'elle risque de passer moi
j'aimerais dire aux gens que en fait
même si on a mal vécu que ce quinquennat
même s'il était violent même s'il était
dur ce sera infiniment pire parce
qu'aujourd'hui on nous fait croire qu'il
y a d'un côté la politique de Manuel
Macron qui est violente socialement qui
appauvrit les gens ça a été dur pour les
étudiants ça a été dur pour les
professeurs ça a été dur pour les
personnes qui se battaient dans la rue
ça a été dur pour les soignants pour les
Hospitaliers ça a été un manque de
respect pour Marine Le Pen ça sera du
coup
vous étiez pas municipal
et vous allez me soutenir pour être
député vous m'avez dit
[Rires]
c'est pour ça que j'ai besoin
de conseil municipal et c'est fini au
moment où je prenais votre chauffeur
juste en bas de la mairie j'ai voté
toutes les délibérations donc oui je
fais bien mon travail d'élu juste avant
de venir oui dernière question vous avez
peur des restrictions de liberté mais
est-ce que vous pensez pas que là
l'année qui s'est qui s'est écoulé on
était en plein dans les restrictions de
liberté et je suis d'accord avec donc
voilà donc en fait ce qu'il explique
c'est que
ça raconte
quelque chose d'autre
vacciner il y aura bien une suite après
on peut dire aux gens fausses vacciner
on n'est pas obligé de leur interdire
d'aller au restaurant
à quelqu'un qui n'est pas encore élu qui
n'a jamais été au responsabilité
exécutive
est-ce que ça vous exécutif quand
l'Assemblée nationale elle va être
contre les droits des femmes dans
l'exécutifrer dire que c'est pour ou
contre les droits et sur l'avortement
typiquement vous voyez ça c'est une
blague de des informations Marine Le Pen
dans son programme ne propose pas la fin
de l'avortement depuis ce programme là
c'est faux mais ça c'est faux